so your office is all the way down at
the end you have your own attached
bathroom by the way oh um here's one of
our best researchers dick hey hello
there what's up dude
glad to see there's another brother in
this stubborn please so this is um gonna
be your assistant Genevieve Genevieve
where's this shining man all black
people have this shine you never shine
with another black person before no I
grew up in a white neighborhood and then
went to Dartmouth
I've met other black people before me
not like this you got to get shined at
by another black person first and then
you get it's kind of like Facebook what
up dude
so every black person has this is Kobe
listen yo what up Wow Denzel Washington
I'm here I'm present and I will always
be around
Lil Jon welcome Greg glad to have you on
board
Oh what's up Barack Obama hmm would that
be something that Barack Obama just
showed up your startup paperwork's right
over here man you gotta be more careful
learning to use the shine tune in and
out otherwise you won't be able to sort
out who's talking
[Music]
Cocco
to drink some Colt 45
[Music]
everything okay right listen for Morgan
Morgan Freeman he will guide you listen
to my voice right now just stay calm
focus on that whitening everything's
going to be okay once you finish up this
paperwork bring it to Jennifer in my
office
now pick up that letter opener
and kill that white man
you
you